people these days will name their kids
anything to get attention
and despite your mother's background and
your grandma's determination to refer to
you as 40 reincarnated
i know better joe goldberg welcome to
suburbia i'm really conflicted about him
and bringing him to life netflix's hit
thriller series u has a brand new teaser
trailer for its third season let's just
say i'm hoping you'll do as i say not as
i do
but for you i can change e.t is breaking
down everything we learned from this
sneak peek but before we do let's recap
what went down in the season two finale
i'm sorry it's very hard to think
clearly in the river of crazy it was
revealed that joe played by penn badgley
is going to be a dad joe no
no i'm pregnant
and in the episode's final moments we
see joe and love played by victoria
pedretti living that suburban life love
looked happy with her baby bump and joe
well he was feeling a little boxed in
and here i am
no one can absolve me
i gotta do the time following that
ominous tease of what's in store for joe
the season three preview dropped some
major new reveals a boy is not what we
expected and i would be lying if i said
the thought of a mini me was purely
exciting and not without uh challenges
and not only is joe and love's baby a
boy we also learned they've named him
henry so what to call you
a name that's strong but not
intimidating
classic but not basic literary of course
because you will grow up in a house full
of books
henry choosing your name is the first of
a lifetime of decisions i made to give
you the best life possible to protect
you to shape who you will become and
before the trailer ends joe asks the
question that will perhaps be looming
over the whole season who are you going
to be
henry the official synopsis for season
three teases that joe will try to be a
committed father and husband but he
remains fearful of his wife's lethal
impulsiveness
but let's not forget this moment from
the season two finale i will figure out
a way
a way to get to you
see you soon
neighbor so is joe's perfect woman
literally the girl next door we'll find
out soon enough when all ten episodes of
season 3 of you drop october 15th on
netflix joe needs justice but what does
that mean like does that mean prison
does that mean
death i don't know meanwhile badgley
offered e.t his perspective of what that
backyard moment teases for joe's future
joe's looking for something that he
can't i mean so the way that i
understand these things is that no one
is born a sociopath or psychopath maybe
that maybe the world of medicine hasn't
decided definitively but i'll go ahead
and say that
we're not born that way we're made that
way we're mate we're made that way by
the by the life we would then receive
the education we receive parents
environment whatever so
i think joe was looking for that which
was taken from him as a child
[Music]